there are some people that i look at
like russell brand
is a conversational genius i i
try to break down what people do and
with so many people i can put their
responses into buckets like tom holland
is going to respond with a funny story
you know rdj is going to make a quip
like and you can emulate those styles
and get them
russell's
spontaneity and his almost the fact that
he's got so many different jokes and
references that he leans into i i gush
over him all the time but i i wish i
could do what he could do and i can't
capture it in a simple model like i can
with some other people uh so there's
definitely
levels and i i can't do what he does
under any circumstances he's like
lexical jujitsu black belt yes yes and
he's capable of going from hilarious
commentary to very value-driven you know
what is the purpose of life within the
span of two sentences which is
super attractive because that's i think
where a lot of us live we want to have
fun but we're also interested in in the
deeper meaning of things
how would you characterize some of the
trends given the fact that you've broken
down russell brand a bunch of times i've
enjoyed some of the videos that you've
done on him what are some of the
principles that we can learn from
russell brand or what some of the uh
characteristics that he relies on
oh man he's
so there's a lot so there's there's the
flirtatious pre
uh enlightenment russell brand which is
if you look at what he does he treats
everyone men and women flirtatiously
which is a general principle for dating
if you want to be a better flirt you
have to flirt with everybody you have to
flirt with men and compliment them you
have to flirt with the older woman who
you're definitely not attracted to
and then of course he flirts with the
beautiful women's who he's sometimes
interviewing and they're they're
giggling about it so that's one of the
things that he does is flirts with the
entire world and what that means is he's
cheeky he's playful he does this we have
a breakdown of push-pull where he
oftentimes will give you a heartfelt
compliment but then relieve the tension
at the end of it by just saying some
sort of uh
a joke that that relieves the tension
and you can see what we're talking about
in the video i can't think of what he
actually does right now
uh so that's one of the big things that
he does
he
also and i guess i don't i have never
been able to figure out how and why he
makes these decisions depending on the
question that you ask him you could get
a totally ridiculous joke answer or the
most sincere
value-driven
heartfelt connection that that you would
ever expect and i can't figure out how
and why he makes the that decision but
he does and it makes him
very fascinating to listen to because
you don't know what's going to come up
from him well that unpredictability
suggests authenticity it suggests that
there isn't an agenda behind this
because you can't predict oh russell's
got asked a question about god here we
go again with the story from when he was
five years old or whatever
yeah and and you know there's people
that i
i love tony robbins but he is so
predictable
if you listen to a tony robbins
interview like i have i've listened to
all of them he's got 30 or 40 stories
and depending on what you ask you're go
you're going to hear one of those
stories told in the same way with the
same punchline because as an educator
and teacher he knows that it has an
intended effect but it definitely does
leave me as someone who has watched a
lot of him wondering if i've ever seen
the real him if i've ever seen behind
that
performative social curtain still love
the guy but yeah you're right it it
totally suggests authenticity when
it seems as if he's genuinely doesn't
know what he's going to say before he
says it it's whatever is surging inside
him in that moment what about the new
russell brand post dmt post
enlightenment
yeah so he's i think still has a lot of
it he's not as flirtatious as he used to
be
i think what he does a fantastic job of
is
being authentic in his positions like
you know where he stands politically but
he can sit down with a candace owens
and be
non-judgmental not assume that she is an
evil person trying to destroy the world
and maintain
a playfulness and curiosity in the face
of ideas that are bitterly opposed to
his ideals and i think that that is
incredibly rare when you see candace
owens talk to anyone else who disagrees
with her because it's going to fall
apart quickly on both sides they're both
going to accuse each other of bad faith
he's genuinely able to or generally able
to maintain
a good faith vibe in any sort of
political or spiritual disagreement
which i think is comes from a place of
actually not thinking that he has all
the answers which you can't fake dude
that's exactly what i had in my head the
fact that he's got strong opinions held
loosely not loose opinions held strongly
yeah yeah um so i could gush about him
over and over what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
you